he's drafted nine years ago seventh
overall by the Cleveland Browns and now
he's getting set for his tenth season in
the National Football League third with
the Pittsburgh Steelers I turn to my
right and he knows what time it is and I
see it's half-past bling boy Hayden good
to see you sir good to see you tonight
is a hell of a watching how are they
there thank you nice little timepiece so
you definitely know what time is it's no
question about that
time to go back to work ten years man
yes yes I'll start with you or the same
question I asked Greg Olson how are you
feeling I'm feeling good you know this
is the healthiest I've been in a while
kind of ended in Cleveland just with me
being a little injury prone ahead sports
hernia surgery but last three seasons
when I've been super healthy I'm really
excited about this year okay
and you know we were talking about it I
know you were back in the green room
with your wife Sarah our poll question
is which quarterback who is aging and we
some reason included Aaron Rodgers in
that group because Brock we didn't want
include Tom Brady didn't say aging okay
which can't be just window closing the
fast Aaron Rodgers Drew Brees Phillip
Rivers and it was Ben Roethlisberger
who's winning the poll right now do you
believe nobody believes in the
Pittsburgh Steelers right now Joe Hayden
um I think that we're not at all time
high there's not a lot of people that do
not too many people that do believe in
this but uh we still I mean I love Ben
we got him he's a great quarterback
still just for me going from Cleveland
having so many different quarterbacks
him and coach Tomlin were two of the
many reasons why I came into Pittsburgh
just disability knowing how good of a
coach he is and then know how good of a
quarterback Ben is so um the idea that
there's no Antonio no loving on billing
no chance you say what did I say that's
crazy you know I mean you can't say
those two dudes are amazing you know
Le'Veon definitely he's my favorite back
in the league and uh Antonio going
against him my whole career twice a year
every year I was just amazing and being
able to practice against him but losing
them is going to be a part we're gonna
have to people got to step up dude you
got to step up
Conor he's amazing running back to so
people just got to step up and we still
got Ben we still got coach T I think
that uh we still got a chance we're
still distillers has Mike Tomlin you
this one would say headline hmm to the
advantage of getting you guys fired up
that nobody believes in you has he used
this point of reference
no he hasn't he hasn't really used the
UM you know he's he's just he believes
in this guy's he thinks that everything
that we got there we still have all of
the pieces
um Coastie is just he's he's a great
coach he's a great motivator and I don't
think that he needs he'd I have to use
any of that stuff
with outside everybody else is doing the
form right so or is it something that
guys are talking about them definitely
definitely um people are always we were
just excited to prove people wrong you
know I said we were underdogs but I
think Ben definitely doesn't feel that
way he still feels like we're we still
got everybody that we need I'm the
defense capable we're gonna step up and
make it happen
Joe Hayden here on the Richards and show
how weird is it for you that many people
think that Browns have a better chance
and I'm it is it is it is kind of weird
I think that they're moving in the right
direction though they got so much talent
now they got the new GM um he's brought
great players there you know Landry um
great draft picks Myles is amazing Baker
did a did a great job as rookie year um
they just got to all see how it goes
together you know them on paper it looks
amazing you know but they got to put it
on the field they got to produce but um
that definitely moving in the right
direction so and you've been here
working out and you see a lot yes okay
and Odell has been there as well good
for knows with him yes last night you
were just with him last yes was he aware
the the GQ piece was coming out today uh
we don't know he didn't okay very good
cuz you know there's a lot of
conversation about Odell today because
he has commented even more about the way
that he in Giants split ways what is
what does he like what is it for a lot
of folks see the Odell on the on the
sidelines here screaming and yelling and
proposing to kick in Nazis like that
what is it he's he's a good dude man
he's really really fun guy
it's just he's in the spotlight big time
you know he's very he's very passionate
he loves the game he wants to be the
best I mean he at the end of the day he
works so hard he definitely puts the
work in and he produces so I will always
see when he always that's all that other
stuff man he's scoring touchdowns he's
getting yards he's doing this thing he's
very very passionate um and sometimes
you get take that the wrong way but I
feel like he loves the game he just
wants to be the best what about going
against him on the per did you line up
against him on the practice field is
that the type of practices you were
doing no no no what kind of I think oh
that was funny going we were supposed to
be doing some one-on-ones and stuff but
uh you know we playing each other twice
a year so he kind of does want to give
away his stuff and I don't want to kind
of so you know it's not the way it works
it is it is so much fun hanging out fun
hanging out but uh we're really really
competitive if he wants to he wants to
get the best of me obviously and I want
to do the same but uh it's it's just
friendly competition but he's definitely
gave away that there has to be so
although we did see it a little bit on
film aney he hits a Quan on a throw last
year for the Giants yeah he did show you
that he can he can connect that field
that field was 80 yards okay who did
this to break everything clear wasn't 60
70 he wasn't a hundred but he threw the
ball 80 yards in the air it was that was
a very very impressive did you know he
had this arm in him
I've seen him thought we've thrown the
ball a couple of times you know I played
quarterback back in my day hurt me
you know high school 7,000 yards you
know 80 touchdowns you know no you know
but yeah doctor probably thought occupy
thought wildest 73 75 at the farthest
play that ad was crazy so I just love
the fact that you're friends and and
this is not like a surprising thing they
know a lot of players are friendly with
each other yeah but when it comes to
being on the practice field there was no
chance that you guys would be lining up
against each other
even though obviously you could make
each other better mhm because there
could be a tell there could be something
that gets picked up some time during
this fall yeah that needs to be picked
up in real time when the chips are down
between the bronze and the Steelers yeah
I love that did you have any really is
it the way it is for
receivers but not all but just I think
me and odo this year it's just I'm
playing I'm and I feel like during the
year I'm gonna be following around I
think a woman we play against traffic
I'll be trying number 30 traveling with
13 so it's definitely another even
inside how you informed him of that or
he just knows he just knows he knows
okay
13 will be shadowed by Joe Hayden I'm
excited for the I I mean I can't I can't
wait for this to happen how do you think
pass interference being reviewable is
gonna affect your life this fall Joe I
mean the game has changed so much for my
rookie year when we could put hands on
people you could load up now you just
have to really legitimately Mara it's
offensive league so I love coach Tomlin
cuz he understands that we're at the
disadvantage you know we really just
have to really work feet really just try
to marry the receiver so you know it's
been switching for the last three years
so I think this is I think I might help
us out a little bit they may be giving
us a little bit more OPI because often
they do get they do get away with a lot
more than we do
so I think this I think it's honestly
helped us out a little boy I've got the
head of NFL rush hour River on coming in
show on sitting in that very seat on
Friday and it does appear that when
because just like anything in review it
will in replay when you open something
up for replay anything that is
reviewable can be reviewed mmm when you
open it up so OPI is reviewable now this
so if you open it up for defensive pass
interference they're gonna be looking at
both players looking to see if the push
offs and all that stuff cuz you know I
mean we understand we've been switching
to them now for the last four or five
years where you really just can't touch
those dudes so if they're looking at it
and seeing that when actually the
receiver was pushing off on him so maybe
we might be able to get a little maybe
get a couple calls it would be
surprising if you don't who is the
toughest guy to garden a league Joe this
it's three for me it was Antonio Odell
and Julio those what makes Julio so
difficult he's he can do everything he's
big strong fast route running a little
bit it just it just him you know he's
six for 220 pounds
I'm running 43 and they don't make him
like that right and the difficulty of
Antonio Brown is what he's so quick his
releases his route running um is the
ability to adjust to the ball in the air
and then if you have him covered for the
first route his scrambled room he's able
to just run another route and I think
with him and Ben their connection with
then being able to just create more time
and maybe you could just get open at all
times Joe Hayden here on the Rich Eisen
show I'm gonna give you a statement that
everybody's making in my industry that
that despite their ability to put up
numbers and it's borne out again in the
poll question that we're asking today
Joey
and that ain't Tonio Brown a lot of
people think Antonio Browns not there
and levian Belle's not there it is a big
problem for production that said that
they're not being they're removing the
drama that they brought is going to be
helpful for the Steelers what would you
say to that losing to dudes like that
that are that great of players I don't I
don't see how you could say you got that
much better you know but I think that
just guys got to step up it's always
next man up I think Ben is definitely
motivated to come out here when people
are talking about how he's his windows
closing and all that he's a great
quarterback called a Fame quarterback
Super Bowl champ and I think he's gonna
just be super motivated to to get the
job done our offensive line is amazing
we got James that's coming into his own
JooJoo coming into his own James
Washington now we got just younger
receivers they're gonna be able to come
step up and I think it's just gonna be
the ball just spread it around to a lot
of guys did levy on just holdout affect
the locker room to affect the wins
losses last year I me maybe maybe maybe
you know I would we would have loved to
have lady on the team 1,000% but the
fact that he wasn't there at one point
did the you know the linemen were we're
saying he needs to be here or whatever I
mean I mean you've been around this
league long and it's a business it's a
tricky business and I think with Le'Veon
lady our situation was completely
different because just the way to still
to do their contracts
I think Watauga early sign for that 45
million guaranteed lady on bells like I
need 45 to 50 million guaranteed I mean
it just it just kind of makes sense but
I that's just something that I think
Kevin and the guys just weren't willing
to do and he stuck to his guns and just
didn't come and play so that just was
businesses business so that part was it
was tough because we wanted him
obviously but I just it just didn't work
out that I can't just to just I guess to
circle back again and put a button on it
the fact that you don't have to answer
those questions this fall I mean we just
asked it and you're gonna you might get
it at the beginning of training camp
when you start this week but then that
that's Tibet and the same thing with
Antonio Brown that he's dynamic button
whatever might happen off the field
that's on hard knocks
yeah that's not in your locker room and
that's gonna be helpful do you think
that that is a fair assessment uh yeah
yeah I think it is I think we're gonna
be able to just literally focus on who's
on the locker room who's went in there
right
cuz now my boy I love a B he's with the
Raiders I love Lady on he's with the
Jets you know I'm saying so now we can
just really figure out what we got going
on James be the best version himself
juju be the best version itself I'm in
defense step up and been you know come
out and ball so when you mention loving
and you're talking about the Beyonce of
running backs right Instagram you know
what you think of that Joe I I was I was
I was laughing so hard I was I was
cracking up cuz lady on man you know he
puts it at the same time I can I
wouldn't have said it but I you know
what he's talking about you know you
kind of get like at the end of the day
he works his tail off he's out in
Florida training and he's he loves the
game obviously you know he puts in the
work but I you know people you got other
things that you like to do you know and
so I think he it kind of I I get it
but I wouldn't have said it well I could
Beyonce doesn't sing 24/7 right there's
what was the target guy that's the
target target guy he's not thinking
about
target guys not rear a kid show LeBron's
not playing basketball Tuesday's you
know is that it later on doing Taco
Tuesday he's in the studio just know is
it LA Fitness cross enough I think he's
gonna get yard secured but I had to say
yeah came out here I mean I think you
know at the end of the day I think he's
all of this stuff were people talking to
me at the end of day like you said you
gotta go out there and perform long as
you perform it's nothing to say nothing
to be said basically and I think he's
he's he's he's one of these my he's my
favorite on the back him and say Quan
but he's gonna go out there and I think
he got to get the job done New York is
gonna give him the opportunity and I
think again he's gonna see when he gets
to New York the Jets are not on the same
level of intensity as the Giants did you
start and say Quan is gonna be drafted
first and all these leagues they're
gonna talk about sake wantonness sake
one that thing lay in the same building
his chip on his shoulder loving owns
chip on his shoulder is gonna be massive
yeah and they have no choice but to give
him the rock 90 million times he's gonna
he's gonna have ops that's for sure I
think he is for sure before I let you go
I mean I know my alma mater lost to
yours in the bowl game so I totally I
guess put my shield up in that regard
that said the kid that you drafted in
the to put right in the middle the
offense yeah but from Michigan he is
special can you tell me what you've seen
out of him
I'm already Joe saying he's he's smart
you know he's in there callin plays um
making checks just really excited from
the see Sammy camp you know playing with
shorts on it is one thing but when you
get those pads on for training camp this
is gonna be something special and uh
he's fast so can't wait to see him in
coverage so I'm just excited for him and
what's the goal for you this year Joe
give me give me a good goal for you my
goal do you write these things down or
no dude no no okay I just just try to go
just be the best just go through the
season healthy make it make it through
the season healthy um help the team win
and I'm just excited this is my 10th
year I was always thinking
like when I get the 10 how I'm gonna
feel I'm gonna do what do you think when
you were drafted about your 10 that
thinks that you've discovered what do
you think I'm just making sure I can
stay healthy and making sure I can still
run you know when you get 30 now it's
crazy they think I'm I'm like a extinct
when I'm cornerback but I still felt
like I got got good feet got the hips
I'm locked and I'm healthy I'm 6-year
Mary got my wife here two kids Sara you
know life is life is good how old are
you kid I got a two year two years nine
months and a six month old
okay Joey and jet did you tell me though
that I thought you said your son told
you about the levy on Instagram no no
that was my friends I said all yours no
yeah not yet okay and then tell me about
your your charity what are you what are
you doing with your charity work one
strong all great you know I'm I'm a
global ambassador for Special Olympics
to my little brother Special Olympic
athlete so we're just trying to raise
awareness with that and getting all
these kids Special Olympics to be
unified try to unify all the sports
making sure they can play football
basketball and um just raising awareness
terrific Joe Hayden at Joe Hayden 23 on
both Twitter and Instagram I really
appreciate you coming down and spending
your final last day of doing whatever
hell you want to do with me no doubt I'd
come in here for sure are you one of my
favorites I've gotten a chance to meet
over the 10 years that you've been in in
the pros coming out of Florida Joe so
congrats on making it to your 10 they
can go tear it up I'll rip it up
appreciate you got it that's Joe Haden
right here for the Pittsburgh Steelers
Joe Manganiello is in the green room I'm
sure he's gonna want to hear okay very
very fired Joe Haden of the Pittsburgh
Steelers right here on the Rich Eisen
show eight four four two oh four rich
number two down don't go in here at Joe
Manganiello and a news update still
lurks for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app